now even though there were certainly
many demons in ancient Mesopotamia it's
important to remember that the modern
idea of demon doesn't really correspond
to the way that the Ancients conceived
of these beings the idea of demons as an
exclusively evil creature associated
with the devil that is out to hurt or
possess humans is one that very much
develops with the writers of early
Christianity ancient people in
pre-christian times had a rather
different conception of demons the word
itself demon comes from the Greek term
Dion and a Dion in ancient Greece was a
much more ambivalent creature basically
a diamon was a spiritual being that
stood in between the gods and humans
diamons were neither good nor evil there
were both good diamons and evil diamons
so while the idea of evil Diamond did
technically exist that was only one
category of this elusive being and would
thus have a slightly more complex
perspective here